telekom ihr velo
fass mich nicht an
ich bin gekommen um ihnen zu helfen naja
leute es ist soweit es wird wieder zeit
dass ich euch den neuesten müller aus
den produktionshallen von rtl2
präsentieren wir uns gemeinsam darüber
lustig machen ich habe schon mal grob
durch die hilfe folge durchgesetzt was
heute anschauen werden und ich kann mich
auf jeden fall so viel sagen es ist
wieder sehr absurden machen sollte auch
ein bisschen anders und zwar hätte ich
zumindest die ersten zehn sekunden
erfolge erstmal so anschauen ohne euch
hätte der folge zu verraten vielleicht
kommt ihr wenn ihr selbst hilft mir
schon selbst darauf welche folge es geht
auf jeden fall machen heute die ganze
zeit genommen anstatt direkt rein zwei
sachen nach vorne weg weiß es noch nicht
machen würde mich freuen wenn ihr mir
auf insgesamt sorgt natürlich auch ganz
wichtig diese gefällt will ich mich auch
sehr über ein abo hier auf youtube
freund das war's soweit vom intro leute
legen wir los
ich bin super team und meine mission ist
die welt zu retten
die absoluten hilfen experten unter euch
werden schon erkannt haben es dreht sich
heute alles um die hilfen erfolge super
timo der retter der welt und dieser teil
unserer hoch geschätzten ratgeber serie
in der wir selbstverständlich bei jeder
einzelnen episode was essentiell wichtig
ist für unser leben lernen dreht sich um
die deutsche aldi version von superman
super timo
[Musik]
es ist er ist der typ ist der typ hat
drauf hat er aufgenommen oder geraucht
oder irgendwas geht es diesmal ohne mit
der wimper zu zucken rentier solchen
park das jetzt bei antalya eine sache
die mich gerade frage leute ist das so
sein normaler modus das ist so normal
wenn er auf der suche nach super mal
aufträgen ist dass er dann so durch die
gegend
er war erst einfach so durch den park
gerannt so ohne erkenntlich grund er
hatte keinen anlass dafür
scheinbar ist es ein normaler art und
weise zu geben also ich merke schon
super mann der kein job für mich wird er
nämlich nach schätzungsweise zehn
minuten krampf in der schulter bekommen
[Musik]
aber ohne witz ich frage mich immer
wieder was motiviert diese leute dazu
beihilfe mitzumachen
ich meine jeder schaut sich ja bevor bei
seiner serie mitspielt erstmal so
verfolgen
so ganz normal also okay was erwartet
mich da sowie sind so die anderen
beispiel da somit wie wirken die leute
in den folgen und dann wäre als normaler
mensch eine reaktion zu sagen oder gar
keinen bock drauf komme
du bist du den hello hello etwas spannt
super timo ist im einsatz
er rennt auch die alte frau zu natürlich
mit erhoben nach hause man muss ja auch
irgendwie erkennen dass er superman des
net er hat ja keine klamotten an die
irgendwie ein deutlich machen dass er
ein superheld ist jetzt quasi zu dieser
alten frau und bietet seine hilfe an und
gab es gibt genau zwei möglichkeiten wie
es ausgehen kann entweder die denke es
kommt wird geistig gestört oder sie
denken dachschaden
fass mich nicht an wenn gekommen um
ihnen zu helfen
na ja man wird mit jeder folge dies so
sehe
wächst in mir das bedürfnis einmal die
menschen zu treffen die sich diese
geschichten heraus denken ich will ich
will dass das ist mittlerweile so fast
so ein wissenschaftliches interesse beim
ihr wisst ihr einfach zu sehen welche
personen steht dahinter und was hat sie
genommen um darauf zu kommen gekommen ja
aber echt mal hallo siehst du das nicht
muss das muss superteam modesto explizit
sagen
unfassbar leute das ist einfach alles
als als superheld heutzutage nicht mehr
leicht ist es nicht mehr leicht
die leute haben keinen respekt mehr und
erkennen nicht mal nicht in ruhe du
willst nur meine tasche klar ist auch
für einen schrott kampfszenen alter
hättet ihr zumindest das realistisch
machen können so dass die frau so also
halbwegs ernsthaft mit der tasche haut
weil so ist es okay du musst jetzt soll
die sagen du musst jetzt kurz gehalten
es ist nämlich so mistkerl lass mich in
ruhe
zu einfach ich will doch ihre tasse
überhaupt nicht klar
meine mission ist die welt zu retten und
heute hätte ich sie deswegen bin ich
hier oder timo ich nehme an dass du
super team im echten leben
timo heiß und dass der name daherkommt
ich kann dir mal so einen ratschlag
unter männern an der stelle mit geben
das ist okay anscheinend brauchen sie
meine hilfe nicht alle leute ihr müsst
erdäpfel auch mal die oma denken das ist
nicht ohne
ok bisschen 1940 geboren und wächst in
so einer welt auf in der natürlich am
anfang keinen fernseher nicht normal
waren internet sowieso nicht geht und
erst dann steht eines tages gefragt bist
nicht oder nur in suchen und dann kommt
so ein geisteskranker an mit einem blau
roten kostüm mit der aufgemalten
bauchmuskeln du willst einfach so
geschockt von diesem erlebnis das ist
einfach aufhört denn nun zu suchen der
den unter vor gesucht so weiter egal am
ende
[Musik]
eine frage heute meint die rtl2 hat so
den kompletten park geräumt dafür um
einfach so psychische schäden an so den
leuten die da bei dem dreh zu sehen
einfach zu verhindern weil ich sehe in
diesem park keine menschenseele die
nicht mitspielt ist es auch aufgabe von
superhelden leute von zigaretten weg zu
bringen als ich meine ich will nicht
sagen aber falls das der fall sein
sollte dann ist glaube ich super team
auf der beruflichen leiter der
superhelden relativ weit unten
anzusiedeln also zwischen verhindern
dass züge entgleisen und ein kleiner
unterschied
was soll das hier gehts noch
dass zigaretten sind giftig und
vergrößerten hodenkrebs habt ihr gehört
ja ok hört man auch super team und alle
freiheit da draußen die noch mitgeben
stenger unterwegs sind denken ein
bisschen drüber nach was ihr da macht
okay zigaretten sind giftig und
verursachen
hodenkrebs kein lungenkrebs also wenn
einer mal erzählt er dass man von
zigaretten lungenkrebs bekommt oder
sonstige erkrankung der atemwege und
herzog hat gehört nur hodenkrebs sonst
nichts was bist du denn fürn freak das
ist meins jetzt geht's noch plot ist
leute der typ war einfach nicht
eingeweiht das ist kein darsteller ist
einfach so wenn du ein passant weniger
abfangen
das aber war das wirklich weh aber ich
muss sagen der typ auch das ganz gut
oder leute also ich war ein super timo
ich glaube die rolle von super timo kann
man nicht gut spielen wird man immer los
aber der typ mit ist gerade eben gesagt
macht es doch ganz gut zigaretten und
alkohol sind schädlich also wir danke
ich lebe aber alkohol zerstört die leber
was soll der mist war bist du etwas bis
zur mitte von frieda jung
super timo das war eine fehlinformation
also ich dachte ihr superhelden seien
eigentlich so medizinisch auf der höhe
was ja gerade eben schon gesagt die
getrennten wirken sie selbstverständlich
nur auf die hoheiten her
dementsprechend wirken auch alkoholische
getränke nicht auf die leber und da soll
weiß ich wollte euch erzählt haben
alkoholische getränke wirken
ausschließlich schädlich auf das linke
schultergelenk
timo hat sich seine eigene scheinwelt
aufgebaut er ist der meinung er ist der
retter der menschen und übersieht völlig
welche grenzüberschreitungen er da
begeht
sorry grenzüberschreitung die einzige
grenze dir gerade überschritten wurde
ist die grenze zu morden schaden
okay weil denn jetzt nicht mehr möglich
ist weil er keine kippen hat tolle
experte weiter
[Musik]
ja sollte falls ihr euch gedacht hatte
dass rtl2 und speziell hilf mir jetzt
eine produktion der region niveau ist ja
eine fernsehsendung dass da wirklich auf
jedes detail geachtet wird oder
zumindest auf das gröbste ist hier
selbstverständlich falsch gib dich mal
dass ihr müsst einfach das kostüm zu
klein sind dass es geht hinten nicht
richtig zu rücken das ist unser
fernsehprogramm in deutschland wo
einfach so hart gespart wird dass ich
mir passende kostüme beschafft werden in
der superman kostüm kostet 20 euro
wohin soll ich ausgebe
[Musik]
kurze zwischenfrage ein super team ich
weiß nicht ob du dich jetzt genau mit
dem auseinandersetzt was du da gerade so
macht wahrscheinlich nicht sonst würde
ich das machen was du machst aber diese
geste die machen nicht um cool zu sein
sondern das macht man weil wenn die
sonne von oben kommt man so schatten auf
den augen hat und besser schauen kann
du stehst hier an der stelle wie wir
alle sehen können aber mitten im wald so
über diesen blättern
warum denn das ich merke schon schnell
zu viele fragen
[Musik]
alter timo was machst du denn da für
einen scheiß was hat das mit superhelden
dasein zu tun dass er jetzt im
baumklettern eigentlich mal auf eine
beeindruckende art und weise ersetze ich
literally auf einen halben meter hohen
astern seinem superman kostüm nicht mal
in der scheinwelt von super timo kann
sowas sinn machen alter timo was machst
du denn da für ein scheiß wie da ist
doch gar kein eichhörnchen blätter okay
können sie bitte kurz auch wenn meine
arbeit unterfranke ich habe dann mit
einem laser auge gesehen wie dann bleibt
den baum hoch fällt es mir jetzt da oben
fest hängt und nicht mehr runter kommt
aber an der stelle kurz akademische
diese hilfen erfolgen sind immer ewig
lang gerade einfach nur drei minuten von
15 minuten 50 angeschaut werden ich
glaube ich glaube ich ein bisschen
krisenfolgen aber ja ich mache morgen
oder übermorgen für euch einen zweiten
teil mit dem dress des videos bis dahin
gerne eure meinung zu dieser
bezaubernden folgen und die kommentare
jacky einfach nicht vorgestellt die ab
und wie gesagt aber richtig auf youtube
und auch insgesamt weiß es nicht gemacht
habt das war es heute so weit von mir
leute macht's gut geschlagen